happy to be talking to professor matthew
fry jacobson about his recent book one
grain of sand
that was published by bloomsbury
academic press in
2019. professor jacobson thanks for
being here with us
today thank you for having me i'm really
delighted to be talking with you
so it was exciting to read your book
about odetta and in particular her album
one grain of sand and i'd love to hear
you talk first about a little bit about
odetta's life and career
and about the family that she was born
into
okay odetta um was born in
depression era alabama um
but left uh for the west coast at a
fairly young age
um she was four or five when her family
left and in that sense
she's very much a child of the great
migration
in that she did get at least a short
experience of the jim crow south and in
fact some of her earliest
memories of of overt racism were on
actually on the train on the way out of
alabama
um but they settled in los angeles um
where she grew up very much in
a kind of more cosmopolitan certainly
than than
alabama um in the sense that her one of
her best
childhood friends was a
japanese-american girl who
ended up being interned shortly after
uh odetta's family moved
to los angeles um
so it was a more mixed and cosmopolitan
kind of setting than
than the one she had been born into but
largely an african-american culture
and largely transplanted and recently
transplanted from
uh from the south her mother um
was what in the day would have been
called probably a
washer woman or perhaps a cleaning woman
but she worked for a theater troupe
and in fact that ended up being odetta's
first connection to the theater it was
it was that community that recognized in
odetta
as a fairly young girl the kind of
talent that she had and that she might
be able to hone and that community
actually pitched in
to sponsor her classical training
so she she was classically trained as a
singer and ultimately a performer she
she goes on to attend
college um in the theater arts um and
really is studying to be a classical
singer she
people talked about her as the next
marian anderson
um which ultimately is something that
she chafed at she as she says i didn't
want to be the next
anything i wanted to be me and she found
her way um
kind of flukishly into the folk
world in um north beach
in the bay area and uh and decided to
to throw aside everything that she had
been trained to
do and to pick up folk music that was in
the early 50s
she'd been in a um
[Music]
on in a theater production and and
probably
there's no question she had a future in
that if she had chosen to stay with it
um she was in finnian's rainbow in 1949
that was the direction she was headed
into but she really chucked it aside in
the early 50s
and by 1954 she's cutting her first
album
um which is a folk album
and i think that is the thing that drew
me
to her as as an object of study
and as i mean just someone who i admire
so much i mean
the beauty of her music and her the
power
of her voice and her her talent is just
um it's majestic um
but i was really interested in that
story of
you know how how does a young
african-american woman
in her you know around 2021
decide that she wants to make this
kind of unheard-of jump from the
classical world that she's been
that she's really been trained for and
reared for
uh into the uncertain world of folk
music
and um i just think it was a it's a
fascinating story from just the
the kind of performance and arts angle
but the politics of it are also
fascinating i mean she
from the beginning really talked about
the folk repertoire as um
[Music]
as a resource for african americans so
her first album is 1954.
um she's already fairly famous
nationally by 1957 1958
um this is a period where there really
was no such thing as african-american
studies in the curriculum
at any level and she recognized the
repertoire
by which i mean you know the field
haulers the prison songs
the blues um as a resource for african
americans to recover their own history
and to know something about
not only where they had been but also to
know something of their resilience
and their their inner strength and power
and that's how she talked about the
repertoire
and she always talked about herself as
both an archivist and
an educator in that sense um other
people talked about her that way too
ultimately um but that was another piece
of it that was just really fascinating
to me and that that really underscored
what an important figure
she was in in her moment
so why don't you take us to one grain of
sand tell us a little bit about
the album and why you decided to write
about one grain of sand
so this was this book was written really
on assignment
for a series that's called 33 and a
third
and the assignment is to pick an album
and
write about it and
i listened i wanted to write about her
um i should say
i mean this project spun out of another
project this there was going to be
an odetta chapter in a much broader book
about the cultural history of the civil
rights era um
so she had been on my mind for some time
um when the opportunity to write for
this series came up
uh i listened to all of her albums and
really thought about
where i wanted to enter this
conversation um
musically there might have been
different choices to make i think most
people
might have chosen her 1957 album
as the one that's maybe that was kind of
her signature
but one grain of sand is by anybody's
measure one of her best albums and one
of her most important
and for me as a historian the most
important thing about it was that it was
it was released in 1963
same year that she appears on the stage
alongside all of those other luminous
figures in both the arts and politics
at the the march on washington um but
it's also
i mean this was the occasion of the
march it was the 100 year
anniversary of the emancipation
proclamation
and so as a historian kind of entering
this work thinking about it as a
historian's meditation
on an artistic production
um that was really compelling because
her repertoire
and her approach to the repertoire
and the the moment of the album's
release
gave me permission to reflect on that
hundred years
of african-american history between
between
the uh emancipation proclamation and the
march on washington and and in a sense
that's
that's how i would describe the book
it's a it's a historian's meditation on
that hundred years
through the lens of odetta's own
artistic and archival practices
and most immediately in advance of the
release of the album on january 1st 1963
what was odetta doing what was happening
in the united states that perhaps
shaped the production of one grain of
sand in advance of its release
on january 1 1963 well she
um you know she had been traveling
through
the the folk world um almost
for 10 years at that point um or just
about 10 years
at that point um and
had been a fairly well-known national
figure
in those circles for the last five of
those years
um this is a moment when to be a folk
singer really was to be something there
was a whole
circuit of of really important folk
venues from the west coast through
uh cities like denver and chicago uh
to um the east coast especially new york
but also
philadelphia and boston and she was
she was really one of the mainstays on
that circuit in the in the late
50s um it was in those years that she
was
um not only honing her craft as a folk
singer but expanding her repertoire she
spent
she spent a good deal of time actually
studying
the you know the old smithsonian lomax
recordings
um in the libraries of the university of
california
when she was still living there she
spent a lot of time
really as a student of the music um
and and recognizing the political import
of the movement
of the of the music she um she never
fancied herself
um a terribly important political figure
even if she totally
felt that there was political import to
what she was trying to do
as a musician so when she showed up um
at the march on washington for example
it was at the invitation of other people
there were other people who said you got
to be there we have to have you there we
need
odetta's voice and as part of this as
part of this and she always answered
that call so
you know that kind of thing had probably
started happening a few years earlier
um so she was she was already well known
on the political circuits at that point
but
um but much more well-known just as as
as a folk singer who had a really deep
and rich kind of repertoire
that reflected something important about
the african-american experience
well it's a beautifully structured book
and you talk about the ways in which
um one grade of sand embodies
odetta's approach to the folk repertoire
says something about how she worked with
the archive of black history and was
also for her a vehicle
for radical expression in your words can
you say a little bit
more about how you organize the book
uh into sections and how you decided
which songs on one grade of sand
to look closely at sure
yeah um well i i will say there were two
pieces of it that were the germs
or the kernels of the whole idea um
one was something i understood very well
and the other was something i
felt i needed to understand but didn't
quite the thing i understood very well
was the significance of that folk
coffeehouse circuit that i just
described to you
as a as a political and social space i
just thought that this
is these venues represented
a really important crossroads in the
culture where
all kinds of people were coming together
uh in an
era when the left really needed that i
mean this is
i think one of the things that we often
forget about the modern civil rights
era is that that the civil rights public
that had existed before the war um
was just decimated by mccarthyism
and by the kind of post-post-war
cold war politics of anti-communism um
and so if if there was going to be
um a revival of a
real robust kind of civil rights
politics as
we know there was um the first thing
that was going to have to happen was
a new um civil rights public was going
to have to be
kind of found and forged and encouraged
and nourished
and you know this is this is in some
ways it's a story that's been told
as the transition from the old left to
the new left it's a story that's
been told in terms of the transition
from the black church
to secular spaces like college campuses
all of that is is important but i think
that these coffee houses in the late 50s
and early 60s were
a place where um
old left folk singers like pete seeger
and the weavers and
new left figures like joan baez and bob
dylan
uh old kind of blues
figures and their publics like huddy
ledbetter and
the kind of alan lomax crowd new
folk singers like odetta herself
um beat poets um it was just a really
protean space where all kinds of people
came together and you could see
at some of these clubs like the gay horn
in chicago
or the hungry eye in san francisco you
might you might
hear odetta singing field hollers one
night
and then and then hear a kind of left
comedian like mort saul the next night
and then hear
um a blacklisted folk singer like will
gear the night after that you know
you just didn't know kind of what you
were going to see from night to night or
week to week and i think that
the publics that cross through those
spaces are um
are really important to the story of of
the early
um the early civil rights um the
post-war
iteration of the civil rights freedom
struggle
so that was a piece that i knew i wanted
to tell
and the song that i chose to do that
with was
cool water which was a kind of folk
standard
uh initially song it's a cowboy song
made most famous probably by roy rogers
although he wasn't the first to do it
um but odetta's version is is just
what she does musically with it is
completely different
it was to serve a very different purpose
she sang it in a metaphorical register
it's a story about it's quite literally
about a cowboy in his horse dying of
thirst in the desert
and she turns it into this kind of
metaphorical
um really powerful um
kind of um allegory about
uh about the cool water of freedom
and being denied that um so i used you
know i used the occasion of that song
and what she does generically and
artistically with that song
to think about the the political work
that was being done
in those coffeehouse spaces by the
cultural work
that singers like her were doing um so
that was that was kind of in place
before i started writing that was
something i knew i wanted to do
the the piece that i knew i needed to
deal with but i didn't know what to do
with it was the
um the song midnight special
which is probably the most famous song
on the album it's a song that
has been done so many times by so many
different people um
it's in some ways the most familiar of
all the songs that's on that that's on
that album
i was always a little bit confused by it
is this it's a song
um the midnight special is a train
and uh the refrain is shine your light
on me
and i never could figure out it's it's
this the lyrics are
clearly it's about a prison house so you
know there's that dimension
it's a little bit hard to follow and i
was never sure whether
shinier light on me meant that the train
was going to redeem
the narrator of the song and and take
him or her away
or whether it was actually a suicide
song
and in researching the song which dates
back to the late 19th century in various
versions
um what i discovered is that you can
find versions that emphasize
one or the other of those things odetta
herself
actually really played with that so her
versions changed over the time
um so that in in the 1957 version that
she cut it's very clearly the song of
redemption
whereas in the 1963 version that's on
one grain of stand she's actually
she's emphasized different things she's
reordered the verses
in such a way that it's clearly a song
about death
on the on the tracks um
so that was just that was a puzzle that
i was trying to figure out figuring out
how to understand the song
but also placing it in the long kind of
long-lived genre of the prison song
which is so important in the
african-american tradition and so
again that was just it was a piece of
a pretty long stretch of
african-american history that could be
meditated upon and told through
the history of the song itself and its
various
um variations over the years and
including odetta's own variations on the
theme
so those were the two pieces i started
with um
and then the two pieces i added one is
um
one is on um the spiritual
kind of strain of the music um and the
other
is on there are two southern songs one
is about the beau weevil
and the other is uh about the old cotton
plantation
um so taking kind of spiritual
geographies and social geographies um
and and again talking about those themes
through
songs on the album that became the
strategy for the album
was to try to think really deeply about
history but to do it
through um the the kinds of
questions and answers that were at hand
in the music
itself you know which is for me i mean
that's one of the things that was such a
delight about working on this project
um there was a lot of freedom in terms
of what i could do
in the um in this assignment um
but that intersection between political
and social history on the one hand
and artistry and cultural production
and genre on the other i mean that's
kind of where i live
as a cultural historian so it just felt
like a really rich opportunity and and
her archive is
um is really quite extraordinary for
that kind of reflection
let me ask you a particular question
about her relationship to religion
which as you said is a primary focus
of one of your four sections so you
quote odetta
registering some distrust of
institutional religion or at least the
leaders of institutional
churches in the post-war period
she would later recall that i didn't
believe anything the ministers said
when the music started i trusted that
did you talk a little bit more about
yeah that was i mean you know this was
not an easy piece of writing for me for
several reasons one
one um i'm not christian
um and and i'm not an african-american
christian
so there's um
[Music]
some sensitivity about how are you gonna
approach materials like this
um so there's that but there's also
i think the historians tendency and i
think this runs pretty deep in
the civil right in civil rights history
as a genre
to take um too literally some of the
liberationist strains of christian
theology
and to kind of map them on to the
politics
of the time and you know and clearly um
that was important it's important
that the black church was such an
importance it was such a crucial site
for the the struggle um
in the 1940s and 50s it's and that
that's you know
where a figure like martin luther king
emerges from
it's crucial that king himself is citing
chapter and verse all the time in his
political oratory
so these things are important but i
think they're they're too easily
oversimplified
um this particular chapter was something
that i struggled with because i think i
oversimplified it myself i really just
tried to read
african-american christianity as
liberation theology
and to kind of to too
fastly read the
um the political symbolism of
the ways that a figure like odetta was
using
the gospels and
i was fortunate to be corrected in that
by our colleague katie lofton
in religious studies who read who read
an early draft of the chapter and said
no
no you have to um you have to understand
that
that christianity is a problem too it's
not just
it's not just the answer to the problem
it's also part of the problem
and she gave me some reading assignments
including a fantastic book by our
another of our colleagues willie
jennings on racism and
and the christian tradition uh along
with many other things and it was
actually through
the rethinking that that
katie laughman had urged that i i
actually found
um some of those quotes including the
one that you just mentioned
from odetta herself talking about
religion in a much more
um problematized way in a richer way
and so one of the things i tried to do
in that chapter is not
not just lose the liberationist strand
of of christian theology and
and christian symbology but also
to try to capture some of the
complexities and even the paradoxes that
are embedded in it in the ways that that
um you know if if it is true that
that christianity um
was one of the symbol systems for
imagining
uh liberation on the part of the slaves
it was also one of the symbol systems
that allowed for slavery in the first
place you know and so to try to really
think about that paradox and to think
about how that carries through
over the 100 years leading up to 1963
when odetta is singing and how she's
kind of positioning herself
in relation to those those paradoxes and
those kind of contending streams
the book in part positions uh odetta
uh in dialogue with contention with some
ways
christian theology christian churches
church goers
all developing at a time in which the
civil rights movement is changing
you also think about odetta as you
mentioned already
um as a figure shaped by the great
migration
and i'd love to hear you talk more about
that um you say
you know that at least a few of her
songs quote
belong to the vast cross genre
hannon of post-migration black
narratives alongside jacob lawrence's
migration series
richard wright's 12 million black voices
langston hughes's one-way ticket or
bessie smith's gulf coast views
so can you say more about how her work
uh produced outside of the south for the
most part
engaged historical and contemporary
conditions in that region and
understandings of the south
so the two songs that i really focus on
in this context
um are um cotton fields
and bowl evil both of which are about
the south but
the argument i try to make is that
they're very much
um they're they're performed
outside of the south and they're
performed
for the most part for people who have
removed themselves from the south
but that that dimension is really
important so they're they're a kind of
backward reflection
on um not just a kind of
um geographical space but a kind of
historical space as well so there's a
temporal and spatial geography to those
songs that i think is is really
important
and um so it's not um
it's not as literally the kind of of
migration narrative um that so many
other
writers and including singers um
made famous um but i think it's it's in
a similar genre in the sense that
um these are songs that could not have
been performed this way
nor been thought of as important in this
way
if they weren't on the other side of the
experience of migration and if they
weren't
in some ways a reflection back onto
a space that had been successfully
escaped i mean that's that i guess is
the
the thing that that really defines them
and it's i think it's very subtle
one of the things i argue is that that
if you listen
really closely and especially in um
in cotton fields i think it's it's most
uh
subtle and maybe you just it takes some
study to really hear it
but there's a kind of agitation in her
version of that
song that um that really speaks about
um the danger and the hazards
uh and the violence of the south um
and what it what it might mean to to
escape it or
what it might mean in the literal
context of the lyrics to be
entrapped within it
so you urge us to think about odetta
alongside many other cultural figures
in the mid and late 20th century and i
just want to throw out some
names that appear uh in your book one
grain of sand and just ask you to
say something about one or more of them
about their relationship to
odetta and her work i'm thinking of
people like paul robeson
josh white woody guthrie pete seeger
nina simone bernice johnson reagan
and others the name that jumps out at me
is
is robson because i think that his
approach
to art
was very much the approach that odetta
herself
adopted and whether whether she got it
directly from him
or indirectly through many of the
mutual acquaintances that they had i'm
not i'm not
sure but um
but his his idea that um
that artistic expression could be
political expression
was absolutely important um to how she
thought about
her task as a singer and
also i mean the way that i think
as a stylist if that's the right word
you know
robeson was famous for performing in
this kind of
operatic mode that disrupted the
expectations
especially of white audiences but um
it just it kind of busted some of the
genres of african-american performance
at the time
in a way that i think was really
important and really powerful
and i think that that is something that
odetta
took as well because
as careful as an archivist as she was
um in studying these old
african-american standards
um in the smithsonian collections and
all like
she was never simply trying to reproduce
what she was hearing
she actually was making the songs her
own in a really
important way and the way i end up
putting it is that she
she inhabits the moral center of a song
more than just reproducing the um
the textures of the archive that she
found it
and i think that that's a similar way
although his style was completely
different i think that robson did
something very similar when
you know when he sang a song with that
just booming operatic voice
um he he was doing something that that
the archive was not giving him
but he was bringing his own special kind
of power to it and i think that that's
that's something that
that she had in common with him
so as an interpreter of the songs that
you write about
some of which many of which were already
in the folk repertoire
you describe how odetta also
um queered the gendered conventions
of music as it was inherited by her can
you talk a little bit about the ways in
which she queered those conventions
yeah i think that that's it's an
important part of
her work i mean some of the things that
she did
well by choosing the repertoire itself i
mean
most of the songs that she performed
came out of a very male
kind of tradition and
some of the things that she did with her
voice
played with a kind of of gender
neutrality or ambiguity that i think was
really important
um to the to the power of the song and
it was something that a lot of critics
at the time
commented on without knowing exactly how
to understand it a lot of white
listeners didn't like it frankly
um they wanted her to sound more like a
lady or appear more like a lady but i
think that
her conscious decision not to be that
performer
was part of how she saw the politics of
what she was doing
i mean it really it was about kind of
disrupting
um disrupting the status quo disrupting
expectation
pushing people to think in new ways and
i think that for her
um you know gender was as important a
part
of that of that project as as race was
now i wanted to invite you to talk a
little bit more about odetta as a
performer
you've written of course extensively
about this album
as a piece as an archive in and of
itself
but you also write in the book about
odetta on stage
what she did for audiences how audiences
understood her in the various settings
in which she performed before and after
1963
so i wonder if you could take us through
some sense of how what audiences would
have seen what they would have
appreciated what they would have heard
had they been in one of odetta's
performances
around the time in which one grain of
sand appeared
well i think that she um
it's important to remember how young she
was um you know she was still
just in her late 20s and so she was
still developing as an artist
and um or maybe early 30s by then but
um she was still developing as an artist
and she was changing and and now
with the advantage of retrospect you can
really see
that she i'm one of the most striking
things about her and this was part of
her power and it was something that she
never stopped using was that classical
training i mean she
she held the stage um
with the kind of majesty of the great
operettic
singers she just did she just um
she held the stage in a way that um she
just looked immovable
she looked as immovable as she sounded
and that was part of
it was part of the power of her
performance in those years
she had a kind of seriousness that um
i think was more characteristic of her
performances in those years than later
on
she she her friends would say was one of
the funniest people you would ever meet
in your life
and there's plenty of evidence for that
and you can hear that
in some of the later live recordings but
but for the most part in the later ones
you don't hear that so much in the late
50s or early 60s
um i think that became more a part of
her kind of stage patter
later on but she
she had a fearsome sense of humor and
she
over time learned how to deploy that but
i think that that was less a part of her
act
um in the years that we're talking about
i think that
the more striking thing um
through probably the late 60s was
just the power of her presence and her
seriousness and purpose
so now you've written about odetta
you've spoken to many people about
odetta you've taught about odetta i know
she's made her way into the courses
um that you've given over the years and
my sense is
from hearing you talk that you think of
her as a person who was profoundly
influential
in the late 20th century but also a
perhaps a person who's not widely
recognized by many people today so can
you talk a little bit more about
how you see the influence of odetta um
on say other musicians you mentioned
this in the book joe people like joe
baez
rhiannon giddens her influence on
politically engaged americans people
like rosa parks
artists like spike lee uh perhaps the
ways we understand african american
history
today love to hear you talk a little bit
more about her perhaps unrecognized
influence
yeah it's interesting and it's one of
the puzzles really that i never
quite resolved is why is it that our
students really
don't know her i mean she's she's almost
unknown among
younger americans right now although i
think that that may be changing my book
it turns out
is the first of a flurry that are going
to be coming out soon about her so
maybe maybe that will change um but it's
it
is really fascinating that um after
about the 70s or maybe the 80s when she
was still she was on a college circuit
like she would she would travel around
she would play at college campuses and
she was still well known
among college students certainly when i
was in college in the 70s and probably
beyond that but then really kind of
drops out
um as someone who is kind of
famous to
a younger generation um which is just
kind of odd because she was truly one of
the most famous performers of her
generation
at the time i mean at the time that
she's um you know
standing next to martin luther king um
in 1963
like you know everybody knew who she was
and everybody knew why she was there
um so it's kind of startling that that
ceased to be the case at some point um
on the other hand
she never stopped being a musician's
musician
and i think she still is very much that
so you you know you mentioned her name
to someone like brianna
giddens and there's an immediate um
enthusiasm and excitement um to talk
about
um you know who she was and her
influence and what she did and
and you know and i've had this i've had
i've been privileged
to have this conversation with with
several
um current singers like like gideon's
um or valerie june um and
you know for them odetta never went away
i mean she never stopped being important
and it's just
it's uh it's one of the important and
and um
[Music]
puzzling perhaps things about about the
arc
of her career and her fame
um that you know bob dylan famously said
that he he picked up a flattop gibson
guitar because of odetta
like that was that was the power of her
influence at the time
um and um somehow
um that just faded for
listeners um and i guess you know folk
as a genre is not nearly as popular now
as it was
you know a generation ago but still you
know people
our students know who woody guthrie was
right but i i rare as the student who
knows
who odetta was until i tell them
well i would just say the book you know
one grain of sand goes a long way
towards um explaining odetta i think for
audiences today and contextualizing her
and using her to help rethink the ways
in which
african-american history from roughly
1863 to roughly 1963 with some
bleeding on both sides um could be was
formulated by her and can be
reinterpreted
with her in mind by by historians
artists and others today
and i guess i just want to ask you by
way of clothing closing if if you have
any
other thoughts about the ways in which
you hope
that the book that you've written will
work in the world
you know what are some of the things
that you would love readers whether
they're
students or fellow academics or others
to appreciate about odetta or to to be
thinking as they
walk away from this book about other
projects that they might
take up or other ways of understanding
the world
i really appreciate the question um
even if i've learned over the years to
try to
be very modest in my ambitions for a
book because when you
send it out into the world you just
never know what people are going to do
with it or how it will be taken up i
guess my fondest hopes would be
twofold one would be that it would um it
would urge
people to to pick up her records again
and listen to them and really think
about
um the brilliance of her
artistry and and the power of the
political work that she did through her
singing
i mean if if um in some small way the
book contributed to
a renewed interest in odetta herself
that would be probably the most a person
could hope for
um you know writing a book um the other
thing i would say though is that there
is something about method
that's embedded in the book that i hope
our students would pick up as well
that that that intersection that i
mentioned before that that zone
where um social and political history
meet culture and the culture industries
and cultural production and artistry and
genre is a really really rich zone
and i would hope that the book might
model
something about cultural analysis and
the ways in which
something as as seemingly self-evident
as a song can actually open up all kinds
of doors for historical inquiry
um so that's that's maybe the the wider
ambition of the book
um but if the you know if the book
achieves anything at all i'll be happy
i think it would change a lot uh matthew
fry jacobs and thank you for talking to
us about your
your most recent book one grain of sand
thank you so much for the invitation
this has really been a delight